right about the greatest garage sale  ever got to pay 20 bucks to a young girl  you see her face how awesome is that  that was my face in 1985 when that bike  rider dropped by and gave me a 10 bill  i'll never forget it literally for the  rest of my life hi guys how are you i  need help i sure do i need to buy a lot  of lemonade from you  hello hi  i'm interested in a large lemonade  please thank you  you keep the change okay oh my gosh  thank you so much you're welcome i'm  gonna pay 10 bucks because this looks  like real this looks like real lemonade  that is that's awesome all right  excuse me okay can i give you 20 for a  large lemonade is that allowed yeah  you cool with that  keep the change  have a great day you're welcome  you're welcome always give back to the  game that started you off  worth 20 bucks